abbas est maintenant une petite
interview spéciale si vous voulez bien
en la gauche part dans la lumière
bien intérim en réalité est ce que vous
êtes déjà piqué dans le porte-monnaie de
votre maman quand vous étiez petit dans
le porte-monnaie de ma maman ans j'ai
sûrement dû prendre de quoi aller
acheter à carambar où ils accueillent de
huit balles quoi est-ce que vous êtes
déjà sortis et que la copine d'un copain
j'ai beaucoup de copains
ouais un commerçant se trompe à votre
avantage en vous rendant l'âme n'ai
voulu fait remarquer oui tout de suite
ça m'arrivait sam sam arrive
malheureusement souvent je trouve que
les gens comptent de plus en plus mal si
votre que tu es fils de commerçants si
vous pensez à vos parents non c'est mon
côté nets j'aime pas qu'on me rende de
l'argent qui ne m'appartient pas c'est
pas l'interview mensonge en a assez non
c'est la vérité vous imaginez un jeu de
l'esprit vous avez un appartement vous
possédez un appartement votre locataire
peut plus payer le loyer c'est un type
odieux mais vraiment odieux
il a deux enfants insupportables voulait
foot est dehors jamais non jeu d'abord
genou pas d'appartement parce que je
voudrais surtout pas me retrouver dans
ce genre de situation j'aime pas ça et
quand j'étais président de l'office
départemental des hlm c'est à dire 30000
logements dans les hauts-de-seine
croyez moi avant d'expulser quelqu'un il
fallait vraiment qu'on puisse pas
arriver à d'autres solutions
j'ai toujours fait en sorte que les gens
soient relogés soit aidé ni des
enquêteurs me des assistants mais aussi
avec l'abbé pierre ou voilà non c'est
moi je les fais par conviction
rien d'autre je les fais je j'ai pas
appuyer temps vous dirait de gauche si
vous continuez comme ça mais je suis pas
de droite à ses seins ce couple non non
je sais pas ce que c'est la gauche et la
droite
j'ai fait gaulliste la gauche s'est
partagé comme j'ai beaucoup d'argent
c'est partagé que les autres c'est à
gueuler pays trop d'infos toute la
journée parce qu'on sait que souvent
vous savez aujourd'hui je sais pas j'ai
pas la presse a dû changer a dû beaucoup
changer la gauche partagée comment vous
avez dit partager partager le pouvoir
non en ce moment on vous cite à l'ordre
du mérite pour un acte héroïque
en fait je n'ai pas fait vous étiez là
quand ça s'est produit et vous c'est pas
vous qui avait sauvé le môme de se faire
écraser
je vous dit rien vous près la médaille
au contraire je la remets à celui qui
l'a fait je le crois moi aussi merci
regarder loin désormais